bonjour nous sommes jeudi 29 janvier
merci de nous retrouver dans philippeco
l'émission qui revient sur votre
actualité économique locale on commence
tout de suite avec les titres de cette
édition
le groupe international s'affront
s'installe à château fort l'inauguration
de la safontaine qui a eu lieu le mardi
nous vous ferons découvrir ce lieu
destiné à la recherche et l'innovation
connaissez-vous les imprimantes 3D cette
technologie n'est plus limitée à
certains privilégiés il est maintenant
possible d'en acheter dans les Yvelines
vous feront découvrir une société qui
s'est spécialisée dans l'impression 3D
ils ont manifesté ils ont protesté les
notaires sont en colère contre la loi
Macron et notamment contre la réforme
des professions réglementées alors que
la loi est en ce moment examinée par
l'Assemblée nationale leur
revendications s'intensifie et la colère
des notaires se sera justement le sujet
de notre entretien pour cela nous sommes
avec Marie bredo bonjour bonsoir vous
êtes notaire associés dans une étude à
Guyancourt nous reviendrons avec vous
sur cette loi et la position des
notaires vis-à-vis de ces réformes mais
avant cela je vous propose de passer en
revue l'actualité de la semaine
je vous lisais en titre cette semaine le
groupe international safran a inaugurer
son nouveau pôle de recherche et
technologie à Châteaufort s'affrontaient
que c'est le nom de ce site il
accueillera notamment 300 chercheurs et
ingénieurs d'ici 2017 il réunit les
pôles innovation et recherche du groupe
et le rapproche surtout du site
stratégique qui est le plateau de Paris
Saclay sur place Yolaine Thorez et
Patrick Jack
ce matin peu après 11 heures Geneviève
fiorazo fait son arrivée sur ce nouveau
site de Paris Saclay et pas des moindres
il s'agit en effet de s'affronter que le
nouveau centre de recherche et
technologies du groupe Safran en
compagnie du PDG et du Directeur du
Centre la secrétaire d'État chargée de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche à inaugurer le site votre
investissement recherche en
développement qui s'élève à 12% de votre
chiffre d'affaires est un exemple pour
l'ensemble des industries françaises
suite au discours place à la visite
guidée du site un site qui appartenait à
un opérateur de télécom il y a encore
plus de 5 ans et qui a ensuite été fermé
pendant plusieurs années aujourd'hui il
renaît enfin mille personnes y
travaillent déjà elle devrait être 1500
fin 2016
on fait des systèmes pour la défense et
puis on fait aussi des systèmes pour la
sécurité donc dans ce centre on va
travailler sur l'ensemble des
technologies qui servent à tous ces
métiers
présentation du nouveau site sur le
territoire de Paris Saclay n'est pas du
au hasard mais bel et bien choisie pour
des critères stratégiques et bien précis
on a besoin d'avoir à proximité ce qu'on
appelle un cluster d'université de
centre de recherche de collecte de
l'industrie qui ont aussi leur centre de
recherche donc il y a vraiment on va
être dans le pôle scientifique et de
recherche industrielle le plus important
en France et à un pôle de rayonnement
mondial donc c'est ça qu'on cherche ici
en fait on est persuadé que l'innovation
nécessite qu'on s'ouvre sur l'extérieur
une ouverture sur l'extérieur félicitée
par la secrétaire d'État qui en profite
aussi pour rappeler l'importance de
l'innovation en matière d'emplois et de
compétitivité
safran a embauché au cours de ces quatre
dernières années 11 villes salariés dont
5000 en France ça montre que
l'innovation c'est bien le levier
essentiel pour faire croître les
entreprises et rendre plus compétitives
en France mais immédiatement à l'export
et crée des emplois l'investissement
global pour ce nouveau site représente
près de 60 millions d'euros et s'élèvera
à plus de 80 millions d'euros d'ici 2018
cette semaine le premier chantier
d'insertion a été inauguré à Trappes
c'est le premier chantier d'insertion du
département dans les Yvelines il s'est
déroulé au square Louis Pergaud il
concernait plusieurs immeubles notamment
le rafraîchissement des peintures c'est
un partenariat qui s'énoué entre le
groupe immobilier 3F et l'association
bleu oxygène développement le principe
10 personnes ont été recrutées pour
réaliser les travaux afin de retrouver
le chemin de l'emploi et acquérir une
formation le chantier a duré un an il a
coûté 300000 euros sur cette année il
sera cela a permis à l'association de
former et de rapprocher de l'emploi 10
personnes retenues pour ce projet
écoutez ces précisions au micro dès le
dimanche
du point de vue financier le bilan on
est si on devait le comparer un travail
classique n'est pas favorable pour
l'entreprise 3F mais il s'agissait pas
là de faire un travail de rentabilité il
s'agissait d'engager un projet on a été
contacté par le bailleur I3F pour
participer à la réhabilitation d'une
partie des cages d'escalier du
patrimoine square Pergaud ATRAP et donc
on a utilisé cette situation de chantier
pour permettre aux salariés en insertion
de développer des compétences dans les
métiers du second œuvre et plus
particulièrement de la peinture et à la
suite du chantier qui s'est étalé sur
une période d'un an de préparer le titre
professionnel peintre en bâtiment et si
on doit faire un petit bilan on en est
tout à fait satisfait
les mondiaux sur pistes de cyclisme
débute le 18 février à 50 ans il est un
peu trop pour commenter les exploits
français on peut parler déjà de la très
bonne opération du vélo Drôme déjà
presque toutes les places ont été
achetées ce qui fait près de 25000
places vendues je rappelle que le prix
déplace échelonne entre 20 et 80 euros
c'est un événement de taille pour
l'agglomération et ce n'est pas les
seules conséquences économiques
attendues si vous n'avez pas encore
acheté vos places sachez qu'il y en aura
quand même quelques-unes à vendre chaque
jour pendant les Mondiaux au guichet du
Vélodrome
et on délaisse les vélos pour passer aux
voitures les autolibes arrivent dans le
département c'est une première on les
Yvelines dès le mois d'avril le service
de location de véhicules électriques
sera mis en place au Chesnay cinq
stations de 6 places avec borne de
rechargement seront installés sur
différentes zones d'activité du Chesnay
en particulier le centre commercial
Parly 2 chacune coûtera à la ville
environ 50000 euros mais
l'investissement devrait être amorti
d'ici 15 ans selon le maire une seconde
commune devrait également être équipée
en juillet c'est vélizy-vie la couplets
cinq stations de 6 places là aussi
seront implantés dans la ville les
travaux devraient commencer très
prochainement je vous propose maintenant
de passer à notre entretien de la
semaine
la loi Macron est examinée depuis lundi
par l'Assemblée nationale cette loi a
fait beaucoup parler d'elle notamment à
propos du travail du dimanche du
problème des transports mais aussi des
professions réglementées les notaires se
sont beaucoup mobilisés et continuent à
le faire il dénonce un drame social à
venir dans leur premier dans leur
profession à cause de ces
réglementations et cette nouvelle loi
nous allons en parler en plateau avec
Marie Bridou qui est notée et qui était
avec nous mais avant cela je vous pose
de regarder un reportage de Mélanie
poquet qui revient sur les craintes des
notaires français et Vinois
255 c'est le nombre d'emplois menacés
dans les Yvelines par la loi Macron
c'est du moins ce qui estime les
notaires la réforme sur les professions
réglementées vise notamment les tarifs
pour introduire plus de concurrence par
exemple pour une vente immobilière quand
on parle des frais de notaire qui
représentent approximativement 7% des
frais et bien il y a un peu plus de 5%
qui reviennent à l'état le notaire ayant
quant à lui partager avec l'autre
notaire à un émolument un honoraires qui
est de l'ordre d'un petit peu moins 1%
des des honoraires alors aujourd'hui le
projet de loi Macron et qui est
d'ailleurs aidé en cela par le rapport
qui a été établi par l'Autorité de la
concurrence veut remettre complètement
en cause cette rémunération de sorte que
nous n'aurons plus les moyens demain
d'exercer notre métier comme il se doit
un quart des études notariales serait
rapidement en cessation de paiement pour
appuyer leurs propos les professionnels
prennent exemple d'une réforme identique
appliquée aux Pays-Bas
depuis 1999 37% des emplois auraient
disparu les tarifs eux auraient augmenté
de plus de 10% dans les transactions
immobilières de 97% pour les Testament
et 60% pour les contrats de mariage
la loi Macron veut aussi instituer la
liberté d'installation et sur ce plan
certains experts y sont favorables
la loi est examinée à l'Assemblée
nationale depuis le lundi 26 janvier les
notaires eux ne baisse pas les bras et
envisagent d'autres manifestations
alors nous sommes avec Marie Bridou en
plateau vous êtes notaire dans une étude
depuis un an et demi vous êtes notaire
associée depuis un an et demi dans cette
étude vous exercez à Guyancourt dans un
cabinet de 16 salariés alors on l'a un
petit peu vu dans le reportage ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer voilà assez
clairement les les revendications des
notaires par rapport à cette loi Macron
on n'a pas de revendications on est
juste très inquiet du contenu du projet
de loi et donc du coup très en colère
parce que il aurait des impacts très
importants ce projet de loi il prévoit
plusieurs choses il prévoit premièrement
une liberté d'installation des notaires
on veut faire croire que il est facile
de devenir notaire et de s'installer
notaire comme ça parce que c'est
compliqué de s'installer en tant que
notaire pour gens qui ne savent pas
comment ça se passe parce que nous
pouvions
bien sûr bien sûr que c'est compliqué
mais je suis l'exemple du fait que on
peut on peut y arriver j'ai pas de
parents en notaire ni de grands-parents
donc quand on veut on on y arrive
maintenant c'est pas facile mais comme
dans plein d'autres professions
on pense dans le notariat qu'il n'y a
pas assez de notaire c'est une évidence
le Conseil supérieur du notariat a
proposé que 1000 notaires puissent
s'installer dans les 5 prochaines années
je pense que c'est tout à fait
raisonnable
ça permettrait à beaucoup de gens de
s'installer dans des conditions sereines
parce que le projet de loi ce qui
propose c'est une liberté d'installation
avec derrière des possibilités de
d'indemnisation des notaires un déjà en
place par ce par les nouveaux installés
donc je j'ai du mal à comprendre comment
ce qui est notamment très important dans
cette réforme c'est notamment la baisse
des tarifs c'est ce qu'on nous propose
c'est ce qu'on met en avant ça c'est un
deuxième aspect qui est le coût de
massue total puisque il y a plusieurs
choses il y a des actes qui te seraient
les tarifs fixes alors qu'ils étaient
proportionnelles au jour d'aujourd'hui
il y a des actes dans lequel on propose
un corridor tarifaire
un véritable corridor de la mort pour
nous
alors on voit de tout parce qu'il y a
des amendements un jour qui sont retirés
le lendemain d'autres lois pas encore
été suivant donc aujourd'hui je pourrais
pas vous dire mais le corridor il faut
il pourrait aller dans certains cas de
plus de plus à moins 30 %
donc ce qui veut dire qu'on serait
obligé de s'aligner sur les -30% et les
actes ne sont pas viables on ne fait pas
des marges à patron cette nouvelle
grille tarifaire dont il est question
Macron donc elle propose de de fixer des
prix précis vous l'avez dit mais une
fourchette de prix sur cela
obligerait quand même les notaires à
baisser leurs tarifs est-ce que c'est
pas une bonne chose parce que c'est vrai
que depuis les ces tarifs ont été fixés
il y a très longtemps ils ont été
révisés en partie il y a pas si
longtemps que ça et ce qui est aussi
très important de savoir c'est que la
Chancellerie était en train de négocier
avec le Conseil supérieur du notariat il
y a un peu plus d'un an une remise à
plat les tarifs donc monsieur Macron a
coupé l'herbe sous le pied de la
chancellerie et a voulu tout reprendre à
son compte on peut pallier
qu'aujourd'hui enfin les actes notariats
enfin payer un notaire lorsqu'ils ça
devient un acte immobilier ça revient
quand même très cher vous comprenez que
non non non non
pas surtout c'est du tout
un acte de ventes
les frais d'acte sont de grosso modo de
7% voire 7,5% pour le notaire il y a
0,825% hors taxes qu'il y ait un ou deux
notaires parce que au jour d'aujourd'hui
le vendeur pour avoir son notaire
l'acquéreur son notaire et les notaires
gagnent la même chose 0 825% c'est qu'il
y ait un ou deux notaires donc il y a
une liberté importante pour l'acheteur
et 0 825% hors taxes non sur sur des
petits actes on perd de l'argent sur des
sur des contrats importants sur
l'immobilier le l'immobilier les prix se
sont envolés les deux dernières
décennies du coup forcément ça vous a
impacté aussi qui sont bénéfique les
prix se sont envolés sauf qu'ils ont
rechuté ces derniers temps et il faut
savoir il faut savoir que on a eu une
inflation de loi dont la dernière en
date la loi allure qui nous impose un
travail supplémentaire colossal depuis
mars 2014 on a eu beaucoup plus de
travail sur les ventes une vente d'un
appartement ça représente 26 heures de
travail puisque avant on n'avait pas
fait les calculs au jour d'aujourd'hui
on a été un petit peu obligé on est un
peu sur la défensive une vente d'un
appartement c'est 26 heures de travail
avec le travail qui à faire sur la
copropriété une vente d'une maison c'est
22 heures de travail donc reprenez sur
les prix moyen sur la sur la ville
nouvelle notamment
nous on va pas aujourd'hui environ pas
ce qu'on pleure sur notre sort on gagne
correctement notre vie mais on n'a pas
de marge de manœuvre si importante que
ça puisque nos études on les achète les
prix de vente ils ont été
validé par la Chancellerie
la plupart des notaires sont endettés
sur de longues périodes et qu'on n'a pas
une si grosse marge de manœuvre que ça
et dans le sens où il faut quand même
lisser les tarifs un moment tarifs
réviser les tarifs on était d'accord
mais en concertation et pas en
concertation avec le ministère de
l'économie c'est pas le ministre c'est
pas notre juge notre ministre de tutelle
c'est justement la connaissance
au métier de notaire il n'y connaissent
rien du tout donc on est inquiet et on
est en colère parce que parce que on est
montré du doigt depuis le mois de
septembre
il y a une politique de désinformation
mais monumentale à notre rencontre
ils disent tout et n'importe quoi donc
maintenant il faut qu'on en arrive à
essayer d'être un peu je voudrais
revenir justement sur les démonstrations
il y en a une première donc le 17
septembre ou alors vous êtes allés
manifester donc place de la République à
Paris donc son il y avait un gros
rassemblement il y a près de 20 000
entre 18 et 20 000 personnes 50 50000
moi j'ai les cheveux de la police qui
parle de 20000 personnes voilà qui qui
sont beaucoup mobilisés il y en a une
autre une autre mobilisation donc le 10
décembre ou là où c'était en
concertation avec les avocats les
mandataires judiciaires les commissaires
priseurs vous êtes vraiment mobilisés là
dessus du point de vue des Français
certains ont l'impression que en fait
vous essayez simplement de défendre vos
acquis et ils ne comprennent pas trop ça
parce que on n'avait jamais vu les
notaires se mobilisaient avant autant
sur un sujet comme ça il y a une chose
importante c'est que on disait 20000 on
n'est pas 20000 notaires on est 9600 on
a 48
000 salariés dans le notariat et les
salariés sont aussi voire plus mobilisés
que les notaires parce que ils ont très
peur ils ont très peur pour leurs
emplois et je suis la première en tant
que que chef d'entreprise à avoir très
peur pour pour mes emplois pour les
emplois que je suis censée défendre et
les salariés puisque vous dites les
notaires il y a pas que les notaires il
y a les salariés les salariés ils ont
monté une association par d'autres la
SPN l'association pour la sauvegarde et
la promotion du notariat et ça ce sont
des salariés donc des salariés
dispensaires et les salariés vont être
plus impactés que les notaires que ça
c'est sûr eux que ça va retomber au jour
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est certain c'est
ce qui s'est passé au Pays-Bas mais vous
par exemple si cette loi passe vous
devrez vous séparer de certaines
personnes dans votre cabinet dans l'état
oui et de combien l'impact que vous
pouvez me dire pour concrètement 30 % de
personnes ça va vous impacter d'accord
ok
pour moi c'est inenvisageable c'est
inenvisageable très bien ça fait c'est
vrai que ça fait un nom assez important
mais qu'est-ce que du coup vous attendez
de la loi est-ce que vous pouvez penser
à des pour parler entre guillemets avec
on me demande que ça on me demande que
ça mais pour l'instant on a porte close
il
y a un vrai problème de communication on
n'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi
est-ce qu'il nous en veulent à ce point
pourquoi vraiment et bien écoutez de
toute façon je pense que la loi n'est
pas encore votée on reviendra on
reviendra dessus parce que quand elle
sera quand elle sera vivement votée
adopté peut-être par l'Assemblée en tout
cas merci
d'être venue sur notre plateau et avoir
répondu à nos questions je vous propose
maintenant de passer aux chiffres de la
semaine
6,3% c'est l'augmentation du taux de
chômage dans les Yvelines par rapport à
l'année dernière les chiffres du chômage
du mois de décembre ont été communiqués
cette semaine entre le mois de novembre
et le mois de décembre 2014 le chômage a
augmenté de 0,8 % dans les Yvelines on
compte aujourd'hui
87170 demandeurs d'emploi dans les
Yvelines ils étaient 81 970 l'année
dernière à la même période ce qui fait
pour un peu plus de 5000 un peu plus de
5000 personnes en plus recensées par
Pôle emploi en Île-de-France chiffréant
hausse de 6,5% sur un an avec plus de
920 000 personnes en situation de
demandeurs d'emploi je vous propose
maintenant de passer à notre partie
magazine avec le métier de la semaine
il est chargé de défendre et de
promouvoir la lecture et au-delà de la
culture plus qu'un simple commerçant le
libraire fait le lien entre les auteurs
et les lecteurs nous avons rencontré
quelques-uns de ces passeurs de textes
qui ont accepté de nous parler de leur
métier des images signées et le dimanche
des petits mots pour plonger dans de
grandes lectures des fiches comme des
billets d'humeur des coups de cœur
derrière lesquels se cachent le travail
du libraire on fait déjà une fiche quand
on a bien aimé le livre et ben voilà
alors on essaie pas de faire un résumé
parce que le résumé il est déjà sur la
quatrième de couverture donc ça n'a
aucun intérêt c'est d'essayer de d'avoir
des mots un petit peu accrocheurs pour
que le client est en vie d'acheter dans
cette librairie de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ils sont 14 à
lire chaque semaine au minimum trois
livres promouvoir les auteurs mais aussi
conseillés et aider les lecteurs perdus
c'est ce que fait Dominique depuis près
de 20 ans où je trouve que la grosse
évolution qui a eu depuis 20 ans c'est
que les gens
ne veulent pas se tromper c'est à dire
le conseil est devenu vraiment très
important chaque semaine les librairies
reçoivent près de 30 nouveaux titres il
faut gérer les stocks organiser les
rayons la passion des lettres est
essentielles comme le sens du
car la librairie reste avant tout un
commerce pour faire ce métier il faut
dire qu'il faut aimer les gens
aimer les accueillir aimer parler avec
eux je crois que les gens attendent
aussi ça dans un dans un commerce et
particulièrement en librairie de
partager les lectures et c'est très
important moi je pense que si on n'aime
pas les gens il faut pas faire ce métier
une profession qui demande beaucoup de
curiosité et un certain bagage culturel
il faut au minimum trois ans d'études
pour devenir libraire il y a plusieurs
filières il y a alien FL qui est
l'institut de formation des libraires
qui est à Vincennes et qui prépare en
deux ans un brevet de libraire il y a
aussi des DUT métiers du livre il y en a
une à Saint-Cloud et qui prépare soit au
métier de l'édition soit métier de
libraire et après les gens rentrent soit
en apprentissage font trois semaines
d'apprentissage en magasin et une
semaine de cours mais c'est la meilleure
façon de rentrer de plein pied dans le
livre Les deux périodes cruciales pour
les librairies sont le mois de septembre
et le mois de janvier avec les nombreux
prix distribués aux auteurs lors de ces
rentrées littéraires environ 600 romans
sont édités bien qu'avec la crise ce
nombre temps à diminuer en 2013 près de
440 millions d'exemplaires ont été
vendus un nombre en baisse de 2,1% par
rapport à 2012 la rentabilité de la
librairie c'est la rentabilité la plus
basse dans le commerce puisque nous nous
sommes tenus par le prix du livre imposé
par les éditeurs et nous nous vivons de
la remise que nous font les éditeurs
c'est à dire environ 35% avec près de
3000 professionnels la France à l'un des
réseaux de librairies indépendante les
plus denses au monde malgré la
concurrence d'Internet la librairie
française reste le premier lieu d'achat
du livre en 2013
l'entreprise de la semaine n'imprime pas
des livres mais toutes sortes d'objets
restaient avec nous pour découvrir
l'impression 3D
l'impression 3D vous en avez beaucoup
entendu parler cette technologie
futuriste permet de réaliser de plus en
plus d'objets des voitures jusqu'aux
immeubles il existe encore peu
d'entreprises en France sur ce secteur
d'une d'elle et dans les Yvelines à
Bailly trois démodias 3 démoniaques
pardon nous avons rencontré son
fondateur il imprime des objets et vent
également ces imprimantes un peu
spéciales et vous allez le voir avec ces
images de Patrick Jacques Ludin de
Dixmude c'est assez impressionnant
sous vos yeux l'impression en trois
dimensions à partir d'un dessin sur
ordinateur né un objet c'est le principe
de l'imprimante 3D si vous avez des
exemples de choses imprimées en 3D
qu'on a ici un maillage est imprimé en
une seule fois des petits objets souples
ou durs tout dépend de la matière
utilisée parmi elles du plastique
mélangé à du grès ou encore du
polychrome c'est du polyamide et en fait
c'est fait à partir de d'amidon de maïs
donc c'est 100% recyclable et 100%
biodégradable chacune on leur
particularités
de bois donc ça c'est marrant à imprimer
parce que quand on imprime on a
l'impression de faire des trous avec une
perceuse dans du bois on a l'odeur du
bois brûlé à la base un dessin en trois
dimensions fait sur logiciel puis il ne
reste plus qu'à imprimer ici la tête
d'impression cette petite chose qui
chauffe le plastique pour l'amener à une
température où il va fondre
on démarre et quand il aura atteint la
bonne température et bien la pièce va
commencer à s'imprimer
quand il décide en avril dernier de se
reconvertir dans l'impression 3D ancien
photographer et reprographeur selon lui
ce type de produit est encore trop
méconnu mais à terme il pourrait offrir
une alternative à la fabrication
dans la plasturgie on fait des moules
des moules contre relativement cher
quand on a besoin de faire des
pré-séries où on va faire 50 exemplaires
sans exemplaires le plus simple c'est
effectivement de passer par l'impression
3D ou là on va pouvoir directement
fabriquer les pièces en 30 minutes
Eric imprime ce décapsuleur pris de
revient à peine 25 centimes en plus
d'imprimer des commandes spécifiques ils
vend ses imprimantes fabriquées en
France le kit est vendu à 629 euros et
699 pour la machine montée ces machines
sont parmi les moins chères du secteur
les prix de certaines imprimantes
professionnelles peuvent monter jusqu'à
20 euros pour l'instant c'est encore un
marché de niche pour l'instant on
s'oriente plus sur des réseaux de
bricoleur sur des gens qui font des jeux
de figurines ou des choses comme ça qui
vont effectivement voir l'utilité
d'avoir une imprimante 3D pour fabriquer
pour un bricoleur pour fabriquer des
pièces qui trouvera jamais dans le
commerce depuis son ouverture
Eric constate un engouement grandissant
pour ses machines il y a moins d'un an
il existait une dizaine d'entreprises
commercialisant des imprimantes 3D
aujourd'hui elles sont plus de 50 en
France pourtant les particuliers aux
encore peu selon ses mais ce n'est selon
Eric qu'une question de temps
aujourd'hui tout le monde a au moins une
imprimante papier chez lui en 5 10 ans
tout le monde aura une imprimante 3D
chez lui en France sans mille
imprimantes 3D ont été vendus en 2014
selon l'institut de recherche américaine
Gartner ce chiffre devrait doubler en
il est maintenant temps passe il est
maintenant temps de passer à l'agenda la
semaine prochaine c'est la 19e semaine
de l'emploi à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
elle se déroule du 6 au 14 février et
regroupe de nombreux événements comme
des rencontres des ateliers des réunions
d'information et notamment le forum de
la formation au métier destiné aux
jeunes qui a lieu au Pavillon
Waldeck-Rousseau le 6 et 7 février mais
avant cela deux rendez-vous pour se
préparer justement à cette semaine de
l'emploi le 3 février la Cité des
métiers organise un atelier de
préparation sur le thème convaincre en
deux minutes il se déroule dans
l'après-midi de 14h à 16h et ouvert à
tous enfin le lendemain le mercredi 4 il
y aura un atelier numérique d'aide à
l'emploi à 17h30 à la médiathèque du
canal à Montigny-le-Bretonneux la
Semaine de l'emploi nous aurons
l'occasion de vous en reparler dans
notre prochaine émission donc de la
semaine prochaine c'est la fin
maintenant de notre émission je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivi et je vous
donne rendez-vous donc la semaine
prochaine on février pour un prochain
numéro de philo très bonne soirée